allez
[Musique]
et
la femme que j'ai rencontrée quand
c'était beaucoup plus jeune
qu'aujourd'hui en rejoignant cet atelier
de théâtre il est tombé amoureux de son
professeur brigitte au 11e jeu son
écoute
c'est tout ça vous avez toujours l'air
étonné que les époux soit bonne et d'un
mari serait temps d'évoluer un peu
dernier motif alors
situation encore si si il faut attaquer
il faut ce rythme je me dis que je suis
toujours trop long
[Applaudissements]
je suis en vacances à la plage je vais
pas m'habiller en combinaison pasquet
paris match mais c'est pas moi qui fais
la une de paris match choc om projet
toujours été prête à taux plein temps je
me prête à tout avec lui c'est la femme
de ma vie
[Musique]